joining us now to share some of her good
news before we say good night self-made
businesswoman and former reality TV star
Bethenny Frankel her be strong
initiative is working in partnership
with the global empowerment mission
Bethenny great to have you with us I see
these tweets about masks lunch for kids
all kinds of things that you're trying
to put together you're the kind of
celebrity when we see you leveraging
these things for good it inspires all of
us so tell us what you're doing with
covin the most important thing that
these strong is doing is sourcing
vetting buying and distributing key
protective gear for healthcare workers
firefighters police officers we have
already distributed over 16 million
dollars worth of aid for these people we
have hit over 15 States and we are
working day and night securing the
proper masks hazmat suits we sent a
million hazmat suits to Governor Cuomo
200,000 masks to de Blasio and we are
just working to supply a nationwide to
health care workers and hospitals and
clinics that are desperate for this
protective equipment these people are
risking their lives the same to save
ours yeah absolutely
ok how are you able to do this when
there's been such a conversation about
trying to get these masks and PPE routed
to the right people and the amount that
they need I just feel that we cut
through the red tape and for every 9
warehouses there's only one that has
real aid that's not counterfeit that is
accurate information that isn't price
gouging and hoarding so we are going
around the country to warehouses
inspecting aid and acquiring it and
distributing it and we are just hustling
we are not stop and it is working and
we're moving quickly Billy Joel donated
half a million dollars and his aid was
out the door the next day
milah and matthew mcconaughey just
donated a big amount today their aid
will be out the next day we are moving
very quickly working with about 10 state
governments and also working just
raising money from the public for all
those poor hospitals they can't afford
to buy the PPE even if it were available
yeah quickly tell us about the people
because I mean you're taking $10
donations those add up how can people if
they're watching right now quickly get
involved please donate to Bethany be th
en NY slash be strong the small
donations do add up posting and the
media the connectivity and we are
transparent you can look at my Instagram
and you can see exactly where every
dollar goes 100 percent goes to the
effort so my partners and I'd be strong
and global empowerment mission are
working for those who are working to
save our lives
yeah well we'd love to watching you do
this in Puerto Rico and many other
hard-hit areas when you're able to
leverage call up the celebrity friends
anybody who can help an average
Americans all of us can weigh in and
help as well so Bethany thank you for
what you're doing it inspires the rest
of it and we just wish you all the best
in this effort thank you and the
Americans helping are not average at all
they're making this happen they made me
aware of it yeah they absolutely are and
they're the stars coming out to help
each other thanks Bethany